[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv soit 118 consacré
évidemment ce mois ci aux résultats des
élections européennes
plusieurs yvelinois avant siéger à
strasbourg par me munir sa tour il sera
notre invité dès le début de cette
émission conseiller régional conseiller
municipal aux mureaux nous évoquerons
avec lui le bon score des verts qui se
classe deuxième dans le département des
yvelines
il nous dira aussi les sujets qu'ils
souhaitent peau à peau ah bah oui porté
au parlement européen elle s'est fait
élire de justesse en 22e position sur la
liste du rassemblement national elle a
grandi dans les yvelines secrétaire
départemental du rn depuis un peu plus
de 18 mois mathilde andraud et sera
également notre invité le score de son
parti son sentiment sur son élection et
ses idées pour l'europe nous aborderons
ces sujets avec elle
mais avant de parler de politique et de
recevoir nos invités en reportage sur le
joli mois de l'europe qui a débuté au
mois de mai et qui se poursuit en ce
moment un peu partout en ile-de-france
l'occasion de communiquer sur les
actions que mène l'union européenne dans
la région et notamment à saint quentin
en yvelines
regardez ils se sont installés dans une
galerie commerciale des drapeaux
européens des stands pour expliquer les
fonds de l'union européenne et un quizz
pour tenter de gagner un week-end dans
une capitale européenne
l'europe objet politique pour beaucoup
non identifié est très vague et s'est
rapproché des habitants de saint quentin
en yvelines
souvent les citoyens sont peu informés
des actions qui sont financés par
l'europe est une grosse part des fonds
social européen sur le territoire qui
est consacré au retour à l'emploi
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour la rénovation énergétique
de logements mais aussi des associations
locales au service des plus fragiles les
fonds européens finance de nombreux
projets sur le territoire
une découverte pour les passants et
comme si toujours curieuse enseigne
d'hygiène et eau qui vont passer dans
l'après midi c'est très bien ça va les
inscrits
l'opération séduction et communication
du joli mois de l'europe se poursuit en
juin sur toute l'île de france
l'association peut que mu proposera
installé sur un transat l'expérience
d'un concert jardinage à paris le 9 juin
et dans les yvelines à la fin du mois le
13 juin les porteurs de projets et
curieux sont invités à découvrir les
locaux de l'atelier un centre d'affaires
en seine et marne
nous sommes à présent avec mounir
satouri bonsoir bonsoir vous avez 44 ans
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france
conseiller municipal aux mureaux et donc
depuis dimanche 26 mai parlementaires
européens
vous étiez septième sur la liste de
yannick jadot
avant la révélation des résultats aucun
sondage ne donne et les verts à plus de
13% sur sur la france vous n'étiez donc
vous personnellement sûr de rien quant à
votre élection quelle a été votre
réaction dimanche que vous avez appris
que que vous iriez à strasbourg pour
siéger une double surprise et une double
satisfaction
évidemment quand on s'engage et qu'on a
envie d'aller prolonger son engagement
d'élu au parlement européen et qu'on
sait qu'on vient d'être élu c'est une
bonne nouvelle
et puis quand j'ai vu le score et que je
savais que non seulement - j'étais élu
mais plein de copines et copains qui
étaient derrière qui sont pour les uns
implique c'est drôle impliqué sur les
questions sociales pour d'autres
impliqués sur la question d'agriculture
impliqué sur la question des fonds
européens
je me suis dit non
seulement j'ai le plaisir l'honneur de
rentrée au parlement européen mais j'y
rentre avec une équipe de combat avec
une diversité de profils d'expérience
expertise et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose pour le groupe verts au
parlement européen
alors nous en tant que lecteur lambda on
apprend les résultats à 20h est ce que
vous vous saviez un peu avant quand même
que ça sentait bon pour vous et pour vos
camarades
oui et puis on a eu l'ascenseur
émotionnel vers 17 heures les sondeurs
me disait vu le taux de participation ça
ne profite pas d'habitude aux
écologistes
vous êtes plutôt entre 7,8 et en réalité
quand il commençait à avoir les
résultats des communes qui ont fermé à
18h dans un certain nombre d'entre elles
il y avait le vote électronique ont
ensuite très vite
la tendance est là en fait ils ont fini
par comprendre que la participation
n'avait pas coûté aux écologique bien au
contraire elle avait boosté le score des
écologistes
je crois que 20 à 30 minutes avant on
savait qu'on était au delà de 12 alors
maintenant faut vous faire connaître des
électeurs européens et pas commencer par
les électeurs yvelinois quel est votre
rapport à vous par exemple à l'union
européenne à l'idée d'europe
est ce que c'était un projet de longue
date d'aller au parlement européen un
sujet qui vous intéresse depuis
longtemps moi j'ai le plaisir de
connaître leur repas travers les fonds
repère depuis très longtemps j'ai été
conseiller en insertion professionnelle
et je me suis occupé d'une structure
d'insertion et tous les projets
innovants
tous les projets qui permettait
l'accompagnement personnalisé notamment
des bénéficiaires du rmi ou les
personnes en grande précarité ou les
jeunes ont
de moins de 26 ans on les faisait grâce
au fonds social européen des
financements européens donc très tôt en
tant que citoyen et en tant au pdci
professionnels je savais que l'europe
existe et dans le quotidien des
françaises et des français
et puis vous ne l'avez dit je suis
conseiller régional au niveau de la
région on est compétent sur la question
des pollutions sur la question de
l'aménagement des territoires autorités
de gestion aux autorités de gestion pour
les faits un européen et avoir la chance
et le plaisir de l'échelle en europe est
un prolongement de mes engagements vous
avez des connaissances sur le sur le
sujet la semaine a dû est très chargé
pour vous médiatiquement mais
politiquement aussi mercredi cette
semaine vous étiez à bruxelles
vous commencez déjà vous positionner sur
des commissions qui vous intéressent
vous êtes 12 bientôt treize verts
français vous ne pourrez pas tous siéger
à la commission environnement quelle est
votre choix vous vos préférences moi de
par mon parcours à la fois personnelles
professionnelles ce que j'ai fait ou
essayer de faire à la région
ile-de-france et les envies de mes
autres camarades
j'ai envie de m'occuper d'emploi et
d'affaires sociales l'europe s'est
construite jusqu'à maintenant comme un
espace de paix d'abord et ensuite quand
même marché commun l'europe doit écrire
une nouvelle page sociale et de
convergence sur les questions d'emploi
l'europe doit être un levier sur ces
sujets-là peut toujours viser 6 ont vite
vous dire c'est soit ce mandat-là permet
à l'europe de commencer à écrire cette
page et de parler à nos concitoyens
soient les populistes continueront à
prendre de l'espace et l'idée de
l'europe continuera à baisser dans la
l'esprit c'est la dernière chance un peu
comme un président jean claude juncker
en 2014 et déjà la même chose c'est la
commission de la dernière chance les
élections l'anr champ sur la question
sociale et sur la question climatique
c'est le mandat de la deuxième chance et
le parlement européen doit jouer un rôle
important
pourquoi c'est parce que parmi les
différents indices européenne c'est lui
qui est élu par les européens et donc le
parlement doit jouer son rôle et dans le
cas de la construction future de
l'europe le parlement qui donc l'espace
démocratiquement et l'unef doit avoir de
plus en plus des espaces de plus en plus
de prérogatives
un mot sur cette machine que peu de
citoyens connaissent forcément que vous
avez découvert le pas
le monde européen dit que c'est très
impressionnant très compliqué c'est
grand comme building un peu impersonnel
est-ce que c'est l'impression aussi que
vous avez oui c'est un c'est une grosse
machine
il ya beaucoup de monde ça fait peur un
temps pour le rêve c'est impressionnant
parce que quand on tend l'oreille il ya
23 langues qui se parlent au parlement
européen parce que chacun parle sa
langue d'origine
donc quand tu entends la reille on se
rend compte de cette mosaïque de cette
diversité européenne
ses très grands mais on a quelques
points d'appui vienne et la chance
d'être élu à côté d'un certain nombre
d'élus sortants comme yannick jadot
karima delli ou michèle rivasi
le groupe vert est un groupe important
75 élus donc il ya de quoi constituer
une véritable équipe de combat qui est
d'être libres excite wii et qui est de
et d'être un peu guidée dans cette
aventure mais moi j'ai pas envie de
m'enfermer au parlement européen j'ai
envie d'être un parlementaire citoyens
j'ai envie de garder un pied bien
présent sur le terrain aidant notamment
dans les yvelines peut-être j'allais
vous posez la question vous avez overdue
encore trois mandats donc conseiller
régional d'ile-de-france conseiller
municipal aussi aux mureaux est donc
conseillé député européen lequel vous
allez abandonner pour la décision n'est
pas complètement triste parce que ce
n'est pas qu'une aventure personnelle
pour qu'il ya tout ce sont une réflexion
à avoir et de manière collective
je pense très vraisemblablement vu les
premiers échanges que j'ai eus que je
rendrai très certainement mon mandat de
conseiller municipal au bureau mais
c'est pour mieux m'impliquer et aux
mureaux et à l'échelle des yvelines vous
l'avez vu les scores des européennes
notre place comme la deuxième force
oui juste devant le rassemblement nage
la deuxième force politique dans ce
département depuis le début on le disait
nous voulions glissé l'écologie comme la
graine d'espoir entre larnack libéral
emmanuel macron et le hall de populiste
de marine le pen
je veux participer avec d'autres à faire
en sorte que ça de graines traîne que
qu'on puisse s'enraciner au niveau des
politiques locales y compris au niveau
des yvelines est donc l'objectif des
municipales j'irai partout
où il faudra soutenir les copines et les
copains les militantes et les militants
engagés
je participerai à rassembler et à
élargir notre offre
je lance d'ailleurs dès aujourd'hui un
appel à tous les militants écologistes
environnementaux qui se bat contre les
grands projets et six autres du coup
puisque vous parler d'arnaqué libéral en
parlant de la liste des manuels macron
de son programme politique pourtant 30%
dans les yvelines
on sait que le centre aujourd'hui la
droite dans le passé sont très forts
dans les yvelines la gauche a beaucoup
de maintenance département comment vous
allez faire du coup pour pour surfer sur
cette vague des 14 7% pour avoir des
conseillers municipaux pour avoir des
maires il va s qu' il faudra s'allier
avec la république en marche sur
certaines villes certaines communautés
nous notre logique qu'ils aient le choix
qu'on a fait pour les européennes il ya
aucune raison pour que nos chances et la
cohérence de la clarté nous voulons
mettre la question de l'écologie au
centre et notre écologie elle est
humaniste donc toutes celles et tous
ceux qui se reconnaîtront dans cette
écologie humaniste et veulent travailler
avec nous à construire des collectifs de
réflexion pour construire des projets au
niveau local et portait des bisses au
niveau municipal
on n'aura aucun sens si ce sera au tour
de l'écologie est au tour de l'humanisme
si la république en marche salies
derrière vous pourquoi ce nom il n'y a
pas deux il y aura pas d'alliance
appareils y aura pas d'aller aux abois
et qu'on dit doit il ya certains il ya
certains sujets quand on se pose à
calcia par exemple je le porte avec le
député de la 9e circonscription bruno
milian et d'ailleurs comme il est
conseiller régional
on défend parfois des causes communes et
parfois on perd ensemble
face à la majorité de droite de valérie
pécresse mais ils font le choix
d'accompagner une politique libérale
menée par monsieur macron nous nous
pensons que le libéralisme n'est pas un
rempart face au front national sans
donner le groupe sipa le libéralisme n'y
a pas beaucoup de décisions à court de
nature ont avec les citoyens avec les
militants autour de l'écologie autour de
l'humanisme des accords et des groupes
de réflexion et de travail et d'action
niveau local et ça se fera en dehors de
tout temps bout d'appareils d'accord
vous avez la pression peut être
désormais un peu plus pour pour 2020
veut que vous êtes
selon les élections européennes le
deuxième partie départemental je dis
bien selon les élections européennes
est-ce que ça ça vous met une pression
certaine pour avoir des mairies
actuellement en 2020 à cette européenne
on a déjoué tous les pronostics
on a subi beaucoup de critiques qu'on a
tenu bon sur la ligne sur l'authenticité
la cohérence la clarté et aujourd'hui je
suis pas le seul nous sentons le poids
de la responsabilité qui est la nôtre
nous devons absolument sortir du face à
face mortifère entre macro d'un côté
marine le pen de l'autre et aujourd'hui
on a les électeurs ont fait le choix en
disant cet espoir peut venir de
l'écologie est donc cette responsabilité
doit nous peser et doit nous donner un
rôle et aimer dans la méthode est dans
la manière de faire et donc ça tu
exemplarité là un rôle important à jouer
vous avez désormais neuf mois pour faire
ça on suivra évidemment les élections
municipales très attentivement sur
l'antenne de tv 78 merci venir ça tout
vide est revenu sur notre plateau
d'avoir répondu à nos premières
questions européennes on va poursuivre
cette émission dans quelques instants
avec un autre élu issu des yvelines
c'est mathilde andrew et pour le
rassemblement national à ce propos
sachez que le troisièmee vinoy élu
françois et xavier bellamy tête de liste
et l'eire n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
pour cette émission le temps de changer
d'invités prenons un peu de recul à
présent pour évoquer l'histoire de
l'union européenne il y à 40 ans tout
juste était organisé les premières
élections européennes c'était en juin
1979 il y avait évidemment beaucoup
moins de pays beaucoup moins d'électeurs
et les parlementaires européens avaient
aussi beaucoup moins de pouvoir les
précisions avec philippe le guen
coordinateur pour le parlement européen
de la maison jean monnet basée dans les
yvelines le parlement européen
sap est d'abord l'assemblée on
consultative et puis ensuite appris le
nom parlement européen mais il n'avait
qu'un rôle finalement
mineurs consultatif et
n'était pas du tout dans la définition
des législatives est quand même le rôle
principal d'un qu'un parlement doit
avoir c'est de faire les lois donc
on le
réfléchissait en particulier jean monnet
dans son comité d'action pour les états
unis d'europe avait travaillé beaucoup
sur comment rendre ce parlement européen
plus légitime et donc il est évident que
pour le rendre légitime en tant
qu'assemblée
il faut que les députés qu'ils soient là
même si il y avait des députés qui
étaient des députés nationaux et qu'ils
étaient
désigné représentant les états membres
les assemblées nationales dans le
parlement européen il n'était pas
directement élue en tant que le début
député européen parlée par les électeurs
par des citoyens européens
donc c'était ce vers quoi il fallait
attendre ça a été fait pour 1979 mais à
l'époque il faut le rappeler il y en a
eu 60 % de participation en france ces
élections et à l'époque
finalement on a bien vu que les citoyens
appeler cela de leur de leurs voeux même
si le premier parlement entre le premier
parlement de 1979 présidée par simone
veil et aujourd'hui beaucoup de chemin a
été parcouru par ce que le premier
parlement n'avait pas beaucoup de
pouvoir les traités successifs lui l'ont
dotés de plus de pouvoirs
vous savez qu'il y a un pouvoir de
codécision sur sur les législations sur
les lois européennes les textes de
directives les textes de règlement il a
le pouvoir sur le budget de l'union
européenne puisqu'il peut rejeter ce
budget il a le pouvoir aussi de sur la
nomination des membres de la commission
des commissaires et on a déjà vu le
parlement européen rejeté des
candidatures de commissaires et on
poursuit cette émission avec mathilde
andraud et bonsoir ça vous avez 34 ans
vous êtes secrétaire départemental du
rassemblement national depuis presque
deux ans maintenant et donc élue au
parlement européen
vous étiez 22e sur la liste de votre
parti élu de justesse puisque le rn
envoie 23 eurodéputés à strasbourg
racontez-nous à vous aussi votre
réaction quand vous avez su que vous
étiez élu j'imagine que la soirée
électorale a dû être un peu plus longue
pour vous il y avait ce doute sur la 22e
position sur cette élection
ça n'a pas empêché la joie d'éclater la
possibilité d'être devant macron c'était
vraiment l'enjeu c'était marc mettre un
frein à la politique assez démente de
macron donc
au delà de ce nom la joie et après oui
c'est simple sans mots vous n'êtes pas
content mais on n'est pas juste là pour
sa petite personne en politique c'est
pour défendre une idée justement
j'allais vous vous posez la question
votre idée ce que vous allez défendre
vous personnellement quel est votre
rapport à l'union européenne depuis que
vous êtes militante par exemple alors
assez dubitative sur son action enfin
son aspect positif puisque j'attends
toujours de le voir en lui quand c'est
un gouffre financier budgétaire c'est
pas forcément une aide
vin très clair pour aussi bien pour nos
agriculteurs que nos industries et
l'union européenne est quand même lancé
dans une logique de détricotage des
nations et d'ouverture des frontières
même de disparition des frontières donc
ce qui est complètement à contre-courant
de ce qu'on nous nous défendons et donc
j'attends que l'union européenne
devienne plus tôt un espace de
coopération des nations est un lieu
d'expression des peuples et des volonté
populaire n'est ce pas étrange de se
faire élire dans l se faire élire au
sein d'une institution qu'on dénonce
qu'on critique ça va être un peu
particulier comme ben en fait on veut
juste là la re destiné
on les plaint construire ou comme comme
avant comme ça peut être le cas il ya
cinq ans par exemple c'est pour ça que
nous on est vraiment attaché la nuance
entre union européenne et europe nous
sommes européens nous défendons la
notion d'une en fait d'une unité
culturelle et d'entendre politique entre
un continent
mais nous ne voulons pas que cette
institution supplante l'existence même
de nation qui sont elles millénaire
voilà c'est la seule nuance que c'est la
nuance que vous nous nous voulons
apporter et donc non aller dans l'union
européenne c'est le meilleur moyen de
rétablir une union européenne cohérente
avec ce que nous considérons être
l'europe
vous allez devoir siéger au sein de
commissions au parlement européen alors
à la région ile-de-france où vous êtes
et lui aussi c'est la commission santé
la vôtre notamment quel est votre
commission celle que vous allez choisir
alors sentait aussi alors peut-être en
l'occurrence mais je crois que ça a été
largement défendue est préemptée par
le docteur joëlle mélin donc j'attends
de voir en temps comment nous allons
nous organiser et rééquilibrer un peu
les profils en fonction de toutes les
commissions donc j'ai pas de évidemment
j'ai les appétits de la fin la personnel
plus vers toutes les questions sur
défense des droits de l'homme sur les
questions de justice les questions
environnementales aussi je trouve ça
très important et social qu'économique
voilà exactement c'est plus voilà en
profil perrin appétits personnels pour
la chose mais après je me disais du coup
vous êtes vous êtes conseiller régional
aussi secrétaire départemental du
rassemblement national
nouvellement élu au parlement européen
est ce que vous allez garder tous ses
mandats ou alors vous allez devoir ont
quitté un leurre pas forcément le
parlement européen mais un des deux
autres pour travailler on va dire
efficacement mental c'est pas un mandat
on ait fait ça mais normalement qui
j'imagine doit demander beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie
sauf que je pense que tous ses mandats
la façon cohérent avec l'action sur le
terrain
en plus on a on a vraiment un enjeu dans
les yvelines où les cartes ont été
complètement rebattu par là
l'action les faux et puis l'effondrement
des républicains parce que évidemment
tout se redessine à l'aune de cet
effondrement et de nos excellents scores
autour de mende à dijon donc je pense
que le l'échelon le très locale est très
important parce qu'on le voit quand on
s'implante comme à mantes la ville ont
fait de bons scores et lyon diffuse nos
idées tout autour de la municipalité
rassemblement national on va parler de
mantes-la-ville dans quelques instants
sur les problématiques peut-être locale
que vous souhaitez porter au parlement
européen que vous connaissez bien ce qui
est des sujets évinois que vous allez
vous allez porter à strasbourg ou à
bruxelles
alors je pense qu'elles les sujets
environnementaux la voilà les affaires
telles que la cimenterie calcia qu'on
dénonce où il ya évidemment aussi
l'espace numérique les libertés
numériques quand on a un espace comme
saint quentin en yvelines sac et voilà
tous et toutes ces zones l'universitaire
de réflexion sur les industries de
demain
évidemment ça c'est des choses qu'on
peut porter au parlement européen et
mais évidemment je pense qu'il faut
aussi défendre toute la france pas
uniquement les yvelines même si
évidemment il y aura toujours une petite
rio retailing noise on va parler
justement du local finalement quand on
se penche véritablement sur les
résultats locaux je parle c'est le ses
résultats pour le rassemblement national
sont on peut les qualifier de moyens en
terme de voix et en termes de
pourcentage vous êtes en dessous de 2014
mais maman que la vie vous fait un peu
moins de voix qu'il y a cinq ans comment
vous vous qualifiez ses résultats
comment vous les jugez localement jo par
l'impôt est légalement en effet alors
c'est vrai que quand on prend la carte
c'est ça qui est assez intéressant et ça
revient à ce que nos prévisions depuis
longtemps c'était une rupture entre une
franche urbaine plus riches et une
france périphérique et là ça se voit
très concrètement dans les îles une
c'est que nos scores nous les faisons à
la france périphérique beaucoup plus
populaires aux portes de la normandie ou
alors aux portes de l'eure et loir donc
ça c'est vrai que
je pense qu'il ya une sociologie qui a
bougé dans les yvelines
on peut le voir avec l'exemple flagrant
je pense de versailles qui était plutôt
sur un angle normalement un axe très
conservateur qui est normalement porter
vers les républicains là on les retrouve
beaucoup plus voilà complètement chez la
république en marche quand je pense qu'à
une sociologie qui a évolué et il s'est
taillé de mobilité que vous vous bloquez
un certain score décevant
même nos électeurs sont amenés aussi à
bouger vers l'heure où l'eure-et-loir et
c'est vrai que ça c'est des zones pour
le coup on nous montons en terme de
score et ça explique à mon avis pourquoi
aussi dans les yvelines ça se tasse à
une affaire de sociologie maintenant la
vraie rupture elle plus entre droite et
gauche
mais elle est vraiment entre
mondialistes et nationaux etc entre
cette france périphérique et cette
frange ultra urbanisées mais on a
l'impression aussi que d'un point de vue
national ya beaucoup d'électeurs et
l'eire qui se sont laissés séduire
pourra pas dans ces élections par par le
rassemblement national c'est pas
forcément le cas localement puisque vous
le disiez lrc foudre c'est quand même un
territoire central pour les yvelines il
s'est fourré ils sont 4e et on voit que
c'est la république en marche qui est
monté vous qui connaissez commencé en
fait c'est ça je pense que karl marx
avait ravi de vivre nantes et paris
parce que c'est vraiment une affaire de
sociologie il ya
de france qui se regardent n3 essayé en
fait vous pouvez rien faire contre ça
concrètement selon vous il y en a je
pense qu'il ya aussi un travail a
organisé sur les centres urbains parce
que je vois aussi la manière dont ils se
sont emparés de l'écologie le coc logis
qui devient bizarrement un sujet de gens
très urbanisées et pour le climat ces
derniers mois on a eu une fiche
écologique montée c'est vrai que qui est
assez incohérent avec ce la logique
mondialiste que défend aussi bien les
écologistes qui veulent dépasser les
nations et que la république en marche
donc en fait il faut amener les rendre
un peu tout ceci cohérent quand on
défend le local on est obligé de
défendre à des frontières des
municipalités enfin voilà des des
territoires très précis avec des limites
très précises vous êtes déjà j'imagine
projeter vers les élections municipales
de 2020 quelle va être la tactique local
est ce que le but c'est de 2,2 de nouer
des alliances avec les républicains
localement bas qui sont quand même
encore bien ancrée en tout cas d'un
point de vue municipal dans les yvelines
on va voir où en sont mais je pense
qu'en effet la vraie question maintenant
c'est de savoir quel segment politique
qu'ils occupent
je pense qu'ils sont voués à mourir
parce qu'il dit le jeu quitte mans ils
n'ont plus de ils ont plus d espace
entre en marche et nous la très
concrètement
non je pense qu'à une vraie réflexion
qui va s'enclencher avec des personnes
qui sont très bas qui sont orphelines de
tout groupement politique est alors soit
ça va être la défense
concrètement des intérêts locaux la
priorité à la défense de l'emploi de
l'environnement local et auquel cas je
les invite à nous rejoindre et ceux qui
veulent dépasser ça et qui veulent aller
dans des échelons plus gros tels que la
région d'intercommunalité tous eu tous
ces institutions sans visage et
qui ne bénéficie qu'à certains n'ont pas
tous les élections municipales cédant 9
10 mois est ce qu'il ya déjà des
discussions on va dire non officiels qui
ont débuté avec certains élus et elle
avait plus d'un an n'ont pas l'air
spécialement mais voilà ces gens qui se
sentent orphelins peut-être justement
dlr et qui encore ancré en eux cet
attachement alors alors territoire à
leur pays ou alors à leur ville et donc
qui dont les valeurs sont proches des
nôtres prête à titre personnel vous
étiez candidate en 2014 à houilles vous
aviez alors réuni un peu plus de 9 % des
mois sur votre nom vous positionne en
quatrième
est ce que vous serez députée européenne
jusqu'en 2024 ou alors d'autres
tentations tels que municipales peuvent
vous intéresser
je pense qu'en tant que délégué
départemental je vais me consacrer à
l'élaboration des listes sur tout le
département je vais les soutenir ça
serait un peu présomptueux et ça serait
les abandonner juste de tout l'ensemble
de mes responsables locaux que de me
lancer dans une mici palmer c'est en
réflexion
merci mathilde andrew on suivra du coup
ça attentivement bien sûr sur tv 78
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau je vous
rappelle que vous venez d'être élu au
parlement européen
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 euros prochain
numéro
fin juin nous continuerons à découvrir
les nouveaux eurodéputés à strasbourg
cette fois-ci merci à tous et à bientôt
[Musique]
à